let's have a go and see if we can do
this and i'm gonna have to rub this off
in a second but hopefully you're okay
with that
from a naught to a one i've kind of just
broken the first year into two halves
but now i'm gonna do the whole next year
in one hit there's always two things
that happen
which thing happens first you subtract
i'm gonna do withdrawal right so i start
with whatever i had before
i then withdraw sorry not
50. it's 75.
so there's the withdrawal that happened
at the start of the year
and then the second that happens is the
interest calculation right so it gets
multiplied by 1.04
let me pause there are there questions
yeah no worth pausing on not worth
pausing on
okay i'll keep going so again we have
this instinct to want to just use like i
know what this number is it's
a figure that's in my calculator display
okay but i'm actually going to use
this longer line here
because it will serve me better to
establish the pattern okay so
let's go ahead and put in what a1 is i'm
going to put a big square bracket here
so i get this right
here's a1 it's the original million
with a 1.04 interest calculation
then you've got this guy which is the
first
withdrawal it also has an interest
calculation
and then i'm going to break onto the
next line because i need the next column
that's a1 right there that's a1 then i
do the next withdrawal
close my bracket that's everything in
the brackets and then my interest
calculation happens does that make sense
so far so good now at this point
i can say oh i'm starting now to form
like the same kind of scenario that i've
got here you see the powers there are
starting to emerge
you're going to be careful with your
index laws here but
what have i got here i'm still doing a 2
i'm going to expand out everything
so that 1.04 gets multiplied by
everything inside
okay so there's the original million
yep and it's got two lots of that
interest calculation
applied to it right then you've got this
75 000
it's also got two lots that all happened
in the first year
and then i've got the most recent one
right
we'll put it under there
okay now let's pause from it before we
do the next one
and think about how this is similar and
how it's different to the superannuation
question we were doing
last week how's it similar can someone
tell me at least one similarity that
we've got
you're minusing things are minus things
did we do that in superannuation
i feel like that's one of the
differences right
oh yeah okay from here yeah that's
that's building okay what do you say
okay so so this is like things are
getting smaller yeah as we saw it
started a million then it was 962 and
then
whatever okay it keeps going um what do
you see maui
you're establishing a pattern but in
this pattern it's not like
to the power of three to the power of
two to the power one gets to the power
of two to the power
to one ah yeah that's a bit funny isn't
it
my power is here and um it's true
there's a one
implied here which i have not written
but it is helpful so we see the pattern
as clearly as possible
this pattern seems different to the one
like go turn back a page or two to the
superannuate
superannuation questions we were doing
together um we usually had them
going up nice and neatly one two and
then three or four or whatever
it was why is it not like that for this
have i think the powers are not the only
thing that's different
i'd love you to go back turn back a page
or two go back and have a look at your
superannuation question
i want you to think about the thing
that's happening regularly right is the
question
why are there different powers yeah yeah
what's going on here like why is this
not a
a three why isn't it just keeping going
ah very good this whole term here right
please look at
an example of a superannuation question
you did and then have a look at this
look at them side by side right do you
see that this whole term
doesn't have a counterpart in our
superannuation questions
because this is like your endpoint for
superannuation it's like oh i got to a
million dollars hooray right
this guy here is kind of separate to
this gp that's forming
over here does that make sense we're
going to get more and more terms here
that have 75 000
on them because you do it every single
year but that million
it just kind of hangs out there from the
beginning of time right it gets
interested applied to it
but it's not like i have several of
those there's just that one guy sitting
at the front and it's always sitting out
the front
always sitting out the front always
sitting out the front does that make
sense
okay a3 is where the pattern is kind of
established so let's try
and do that by now you're getting the
hang of it right
two things happen every year what are
the two things
right here right that's why we wrote
them down withdrawal and
interest so let's do them one at a time
here comes the withdrawal you start with
wherever you were
at the beginning of the year and then
you subtract
withdrawals done and then what interest
so i'll multiply by 1.04 okay
now here is the previous year
okay so what's going to happen is i'm
going to write that in
it's going to be a bit long and gross
apologies but it is important to
establish the pattern
and then i'm going to subtract the new
75 000 i'm going to use this year in my
retirement so here we go
um here comes a2 i'll do a big square
bracket here
1 million with that
minus this one
minus this one
that's a2 did i get it right does it
look okay i've got all the terms there
right that's a two i then have to
subtract
one more time where am i going to do it
let me do it here
so that's the amount that we just
withdrew at the start of this year close
off my bracket
and then what was the second thing that
happened every year it's the same two
things that happened right
times i'm going to do the interest
calculation multiply by 1.04
now i wonder if you can see the way that
i wrote this line here in a2
i've got this original amount hanging
out the front and then i'm trying to
show
the rest of it kind of flows together
and i'm going to write the next line
my pattern will be established in the
same way here here comes my
a million how much interest
is on it how many years worth
it's three right it's three you can see
at the end of the first year you've got
the one at the end of the second year
you've got the two so now i'm up to
three that was the point of doing a
pattern okay
and then you've got all of these
withdrawals all of these many
withdrawals
they all start with 75 000 right
uh then you've got the first one which
is from the longest time ago
you got the next one
and then you've got the most recent one
have i got enough to establish my
pattern i think so right three terms one
two
three now have a look at what the
question says it says after ten years
right that's where we're going okay so
what i'm going to do at this point is
i'm going to
generalize i'm going to say what about
the nth one okay
so i'm going to say this is a 3 dot
what will a n be
hmm so there's the million hanging out
the front
okay how many times has interest been
applied to this
remember this is the nth case right end
time it'll be end times
however many number of years you've been
after retirement okay
and then we've got these guys okay so
you got 75 000.
the very first withdrawal that you did
right it happened in the same year
as you started this whole thing off
right so it's got how many lots of
interest applied to it
also m and you can even just see the
three and the three they match
so this n and this n must also match so
far so good
then i've got the next one if this one
was
n then the next one down will be
one less than that so n minus one is
that okay
like so and then there's going to be a
whole bunch of them right you've got
every year that you do this
the very last one the very last
withdrawal will always look like this
can you see that in fact i'm just going
to highlight it here in every line
a3 has this one a2
has this one a1 has
this one the last withdrawal always
looks
the same yeah so that's where i'm going
to finish
okay do you remember
we didn't like writing so many terms
right we want to get to
a formula that i can use which captures
all those terms together just like we
did with the
salary question at the beginning okay
now we're almost there but this still
looks gross i think we can make it
better okay does anyone know what's on
the left-hand side i'm about to clear it
off
is that okay